[Musique]
depuis combien de temps est ce qui est
écrit à propos
il vivait sa vie en solitaire
bonjour tout a changé ah non
[Musique]
reste
que le déni si tourmenté moi j'étais
jeune en amour j'étais terrifiée
mais il y fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
moi
je te laisse la vie avec mes problèmes
test ça peut plus continuer
[Musique]
oh
je ne sais pas si je dois continuer à me
battre pour le sauver nous sauvez moi
mais on doit faire une pause tu peux pas
échapper à son destin en déménageant
d'une place à l'autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et les éditeurs se battent pour obtenir
les droits de mon livre je ne peux pas
dévoiler mon histoire au monde entier
c'est notre histoire on a traversé
beaucoup d'épreuves et s'il fait de les
raconter nous permet d'aider d'autres
personnes où est le problème mon livre
parle de pardon et d'amour
inconditionnel et c'est exactement ça
que raconte after aftu c'est mon
histoire après notre rencontre
[Musique]
si tu continues tu y vas te faire c'est
pour ça que tu dois partir tété ou quand
elle avait besoin de toi là tu fait
qu'empirer les choses
[Musique]
ja perd totalement le contrôle quand je
suis avec toi si samedi 2 mai
[Musique]